good evening ladies and gentlemen and uh
welcome to the review committee and
those of you that
in fact everyone's mostly taking your
jackets also you're more comfortable
with no jacket
please take it off should we be required
to evacuate the building would you
please leave the building
via the rear doors to the hall and then
turn right
go through the two sets of double doors
for the car park
which is our assembly point please do
not delay
your evacuation to collect any
belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
and please would you switch off mobiles
or turn them to silent
one additional announcement is that um
you've got the microphones in front of
you so when you're passing them if you
pass the microphone
to another member please would you use
the
antibacterial wipes that are placed on
the desks there
okay thank you agenda item number one
is apologies from for absence and
apologies have been received
from councillor joe mcpherson
agenda item two substitute members
councillor june
lumley is substituting for council joe
mcpherson
agenda item number three non-members
attending
we've got uh councillors cheryl rowe
councillor arthur williams and
councillor simon wooten
attending moving on to a gender item
four minutes of the meeting held on the
13th of april 2021
are these minutes agreed members
thank you the agenda item five to
receive
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest members
there are none none declared
okay agenda item six
is the audit and review of the review
committee
and uh angela law will present the
officer's report
thank you chairman
members the center for governance and
scrutiny has been commissioned to review
the council scrutiny function
and to identify areas for improvement
this report sets out the process
of the center of governance and
scrutiny's audit and review of the
review committee
following following the results of the
lgap review
conducted in 2019. the 2019 peer review
highlighted the council scrutiny
function was a cause for concern which
needed to be strengthened
the peer review proposed that the centre
for governance and scrutiny undertake
the work with rocha district council to
work with members and officers
to ensure that its overview and scrutiny
function is working effectively
and to develop actions to help the
function improve
the audit and review of the review
committee has been
was has been postponed up until this
period due to the impact of
repercussions of the covid19 pandemic
which hit shortly after the completion
of the peer review
this audit in review is based on a tried
and tested methodology utilized by the
governor center of governments and
scrutiny since 2003
and is built around the content of the
2019 statutory scrutiny guidance which
local authorities
must have regard to and the good
scrutiny guide published by the center
in 2019
paragraph four refers to
where the centre of governance of
scrutiny have identified
certain areas of improvement needed
following the peer review
and how the uh the the center of
governance scrutiny will gather evidence
through the four different methods as
listed in 4.2
once all the evidence has been gathered
they will put forward an
action plan for improvements which is
deliverable and focus on ensuring that
scrutiny within the council is working
effectively
it is anticipated that his work will be
completed by late autumn with a report
presented to the review committee in
november
of this year and will in turn make
recommendations to full council
thank you chairman thank you angela
do any members have any questions
on the report council mrs mayest
i would just like to say that we have a
lot of
new members on this committee and some
longer serving members
and i must admit i don't know everyone
sitting around the table
with the chairman mind if we went around
and introduced ourselves because i think
that would help new leaders as well
because i'm sure if i don't know them
they possibly don't know me
okay thanks councilman very good idea i
guess
um before we start council admirers
my name is
[Music]
district residence
thanks for that suggestion council mrs
mason i've spent all day looking at
everyone's photographs
on the website and uh some of you don't
look uh
you look much better in the direction i
would say
thank you councillor wilkinson
oh sorry sorry
i mean it has been some time
but i think that's understandable i'll
just say that i'd like to
see the report be positive in looking
forward not backwards because the
historic problems that we've had
are likely not to be the same because we
have a new committee
with a new chairman and perhaps this new
committee can demonstrate that
the workforce district council overview
scrutiny committee
is not only improving but is good
and it's possible and i remain very
optimistic that
once this review has been done that
hopefully
we will come up with a very small action
plan i would be optimistic enough to say
no actions because
i'm sure we will none of us are perfect
but what we i think we need to be
have a positive spin on this and to
take it with as constructive criticism
and it should be very helpful to all
members thank you
thank you council wilkinson
thank you
is this review um similar
to the peer review in that it's an
advisory
or is this something that will mandate
the council to take on
the actions that it recommends
that makes sense council wilkinson um
one it's it's it's not similar to the
peer review um
they will come in and they will give us
advice and guidance and make
um recommendations whether those
recommendations are to be followed
that's to be discussed by this committee
um some of you might not agree with the
action plan they put forward and or
the improvement but that i think it's
it's
something to be to to to to
be seen as to what they would put
forward it's hard to say at this present
time
but it's not um mandatory
it is a matter for this council
thank you thank you angela and one
further question then
is this forgive me for asking because i
mean i welcome this but i
don't know the history behind it um is
this something that we have
asked for or is this something that has
happened as a result of a peer review
but we've been told this is what's going
to happen to us
chairman it's partly because of the peer
review and also as um as the manchin
officer
responsible governance we've not had a
audit
since 2000 and
2004. so i think it's about time to
ensure
yes that's fine thank you you've asked
my question i mean i i welcome this i
just wanted to know the history behind
it
thank you very much thank you councillor
drew
um thank you chairman i welcome this
uh initiative and i hope um it will
allow us to be much more effective
especially in our role as scrutineers
look forward to receiving the action
plan for improvement but one thing i'd
like to see
and i don't think it's mentioned in the
report not specifically anyway
is additional training for members based
on
any recommendations that come out of the
action plan
not only for members of this committee
but also for
all that accountants thank you
thank you councillor that's a that's a
very good suggestion thank you
could i ask one question actually yeah
of course um
which is that will we rather than wait
to the end of the
report and have it formally handed over
will they be giving us emerging findings
so that we can start to make
improvements straight away
yes that's something you can put forward
to the caseworkers and
you know as chairman you can make that
suggestion
so yeah well thank you
is that a governmental body or is it a
voluntary body or
how is it qualified to make these
judgments
it's actually um a independent national
charity
founded by the local government
association but they are the leading
body
in promoting governance and scrutiny
they have a strong track record and they
help ministers
draft policy in governance and scrutiny
so they do
they do work up and down the country and
with various organizations
okay thank you council mrs mason
we normally have a review training
session i don't recall
seeing it on the training brochure
forgive me if i'm wrong please educate
me but
i don't recall seeing it i do think
especially with so many new
so members the officers can tell us if
that has been arranged or not
um your comments noted counselor mrs
mason i'll make sure that but um
training is part of the remit that i've
asked the center of governance and
security to look at as well
as to what training needs members will
need
members there is one recommendation set
out paragraph
9.1 on page 6.3 of the report
and that is to note the process for
undertaking the audit and review
of the operation of the review committee
is that noted members
thank you moving on to
item seven the key decisions document
and i would just make the point that
none of these decisions have yet been
taken and what i propose to do
if you'll indulge me is just to go
through page by page
and ask
if anyone has any questions or any
observations
on any of the items so if we look at
page two
of item eight and we've got two key
decisions the environmental health
service plan
2020 to 21 and the modern slavery act
2015.
does anyone wish to comment or make
observations
thank you moving on to page three
and we've got three decisions the
suspension of parking charges on
saturdays before christmas
voluntary sector grant allocations
2022-23
the connect program investor saved
business case
and pipeline of projects
okay moving on to page four we've got
two decisions
the association of south essex local
authorities
and the parks for nature
moving on to the final decision waste
transfer
arrangements
okay thank you members
item number eight is the work plan
and the work plan hasn't been filled up
as the review of the work of the
committee will be commencing this month
as part of the work that will be
undertaken for the audit and one of the
areas that's going to be covered by the
review
will be how this committee approaches
its work programme
if anyone's got any topics that they
would like to suggest
at this meeting officers are happy to
take note of that
um for discussion with the relevant
officers to see where they might be best
uh inserted into the work plan
does anyone have any questions on the
work plan or suggestions council mr
mason
thank you mr chair one thing i would
like us
to look at and i don't recall the news
committee
actually ever looking at it
policy and is not talking about refuse
i'm talking about
a litter from waste bins and around the
area i think we've all seen on social
media that this is becoming
quite a problem and i think we need to
look at the procedure
that we have in place whether it's
effective
and also i know quite a lot of
waste bins were removed by the council
whether that has had an effect on the
problem we have
to look at um if our policy covers
prevention
as well as cure of litter and the
other thing that's very nicely missing
in the litter bins
that we provide for the public use in
public places is
any element of recycling and as this
council
is looking and proud of its recycling
i don't know if that's because it's not
being covered in the policy
at all so i think this committee could
do well to look at
our policy and perhaps raise some
questions
and see if areas need to be looked at
further by
the portfolio okay
thank you cancer dry
thank you chairman some time ago
i understand a working group i set up to
look at a policy
as to how district council can help
residents in relation to issues
with their management companies i don't
know if
any if there was any conclusion in
respect to that
working group
yes
mr chairman if i may i can probably
elaborate on that for you
and as the chairman of that working
group we
had we asked officers to provide us with
information that
unfortunately
wasn't forthcoming and took us quite
some time about a year over a year i
think
but we have now got that information and
the working group has
convened and actually has a meeting on
the 10th so we will be meeting on the
10th
but unfortunately because of the
lack of information we couldn't progress
we are now in a position to progress
hopefully
does that answer your question council
direct
through you mr chairman yes i'd still
like it be investigated further if
necessary part
of the work work plan yeah thank you
council wilkinson
um one thing i just wanted to ask was am
i writing thinking i think i am that the
carbon neutral working group sub was a
working group in this committee
that right yes yeah okay yeah i noticed
that doesn't feature at all on the work
plan
are we is there going to be any updates
at all because i
haven't heard any updates from that
working group for a little while and i'm
just
not sure how we're going to get that how
does that report back into the review
does it need to be on the work plan does
it just report back it doesn't win
we could well we could make it in the
genderizer
and when it uh as and when it meets it
will uh report back
into this committee uh council wilkinson
okay so it's not been passed over to the
portfolio holder for environment then
um i would have to um
i would have to actually get an update
from uh from uh from the from the ad on
that and
uh update you outside the meeting okay
chairman three years for mary um is it
possible to get an update because
obviously this is a
it is an important subject which we
voted on back in 2019 i think from
memory
um and a lot of us feel i think all of
us actually feel very
strongly about it and for it not to
feature on our work plan at all for the
year is a little bit concerning that's
all i'll just be keen to get
some ideas how that's progressing
thank you yeah we've noted and we'll
take that forward let's cancel
um
right thank you yes um send the thoughts
to the council welcome to them
um i wonder why emergency planning isn't
included in the work
very recently to this uh committee uh
councillor foster so um you know
there isn't a sort of there isn't unless
there's a particular focus
uh you know that committee wants um you
know it's it's difficult to include on
the work plan um is there anything
in particular that you would that you
would actually like the committee to
focus on in terms of emergency planning
please
i may come back to that thank you
any other members wish to comment on the
work plan
that is the final agenda item
and so the meeting is closed at
20 53
sorry 1953 working on
summer time